bonjour nous sommes le jeudi 16 avril
merci de nous retrouver pour ce nouveau
numéro de filecho votre émission qui
revient sur l'actualité économique
locale on commence tout de suite avec
les titre de cette édition la CVS que la
Société des Eaux de Versailles et de
saint-clou a inauguré nouveau siège
social à trrappe l'occasion de parler
des nouveaux projets pour
l'agglomération la fin du challenge way
up tour ski c'était mardi nous
reviendrons sur l'actualité de cette
start-up dont nous avons suivi le
parcours et aussi sur l'importance du
courvoiturage pour les entreprises vous
découvrirez également bbound une
start-up versaillaise qui rayonne à
l'international avec ses solutions
Internet innovantes pour les smartphones
et notre entretien sera consacré au Plan
de Déplacement entreprise il est
obligatoire pour les sociétés donc plus
de 500 salariés utilisent leurs
véhicules pour leur travail nous en
parlerons avec mes deux invités en
plateau avec moi Bernard bord chargé
secrétaire de l'association Horizon
employeur et chargé de mission chez d'O
système et François Bellini vous êtes
élu à la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de Versailles Eveline
bonsoir mais avant cela je vous propose
de passer en revue l'actualité
économique de la
semaine et nous ouvrons cette partie
actualité en parlant du Grand Paris en
Île-de-France 33 sites seront bientôt à
l'étude dans les ivelines C sites sont
étudiés pour construire près de 17500
logements parmi eux Versailles
saint-serlécole avec 10000 logements
prévus mais aussi l'hippodrome de
Rambouillet les abords des gardes du
Transilien à Rambouillet et coanière une
nouvelle qui n'est pas bien accueillie
par tous le président du conseil général
Pierre Bédier est opposé à certains des
projets le département des iblines
conjointement avec celui du Valdois
souhaite d'ailleurs faire annuler la
création du nouvel établissement public
fonciers pour sauvegarder sa
souveraineté ce dernier pourrait
remplacer les les établissements publics
fonciers
départementaux enfin je vous le disais
en titre la semaine dernière la cvesque
donc la Société des Eaux de Versailles
et de saint-clou a inauguré son siège
social à trrappe une façon de
s'implanter encore plus fortement dans
le territoire et de lancer de nouveaux
projets sur l'agglomération un reportage
de Michel elmidoro et Patrick Jacques de
dixm une inauguration en terrain connu
l'installation à trrappe du siège social
et de 30 salariés de la cvesque est une
étape de plus dans la continuité de son
activité cela fait 30 ans qu'elle est
partenaire de la collectivité pour 80 %
de l'assainissement et pour la totalité
des EAU du territoire on avait un
objectif double c'est-à-dire d'avoir une
base bah opérationnelle avec bah des
locos techniques dans lequel on est
aujourd'hui et puis être au cœur du
territoire et avoir une implantation qui
permettent à nos agents pouvoir rayonner
au sein de la casquille de manière
efficace ce point un ancrage s'ajoute à
celui de la station dépuration de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline une meilleure
implantation nécessaire car la filiale
de suè Environnement a de nouveaux
projet pour l'agglomération l'un d'entre
eux particulièrement emblématique ne
devrait pas tarder à sortir de terre
c'est la station d'épuration
d'élancour sur lequel va être installé
dans les prochains les prochains mois la
première pierre devra être inaugurée
relativement rapidement dans les
prochaines semaines un système de
récupération du biogaz produit dans la
station des tion biogaz qui sera traité
purifié et réinjecté dans le réseau de
gaz de France de GrDF de telle façon à
éviter la consommation d'énergie fossile
cette réalisation d'une unité de
valorisation du biogaz pourrait produire
80000 tonnes de biométhane par an elle
devrait être mise en service avant le
1er mars 2017
50 % des jeunes de 18 à 24 ans
souhaitent créer leur propre entreprise
c'est le résultat d'un sondage ID invest
en partenariat avec Le Figaro pour
répondre à ses envies dans le cadre de
ses activités pédagogiques l'ISM
l'Institut supérieur de management a
organisé une conférence lundi à
l'université de sa-quanttin en Yveline
sur le thème entrepreneuriat et création
d'entreprise comment y parvenir avec les
réseaux d'accompagnement de jeunes
entrepreneurs étaient présents pour
parler de leur expérience ainsi que des
professionnels je vous propose d'écouter
ces
précisions le but de de cette rencontre
c'est véritablement donner envie aux
jeunes de créer leur entreprise et par
là de créer leur emploi donc aujourd'hui
c'est tout à fait possible grâce à des
réseaux d'accompagnement on a deux
réseaux ici présents on a initiative
France et on a le Réseau Entreprendre
qui vont accompagner les jeunes et
sécuriser en quelque sorte leur projet
je pense que culturellement en France la
création d'entreprise est pas si naturel
que cela et donc il faut faire avancer
cette culture ensuite on a dit beaucoup
de mal sur la difficulté de créer une
entreprise les problèmes de financement
alors justement aujourd'hui on va
essayer d'expliquer que un c'est pas
compliqué que ça et c'est même pas plus
compliqué que dans d'autres pays
d'Europe et que des réseaux de
financement il y en a de plus en plus
qui aident les porteurs de projets avec
un bon projet et nous parlons voiture
maintenant ou plutôt covoiturage nous
vous avions déjà parlé de la start-up
WAZ up en janvier 2014 elle propose une
application mobile pour mettre en
relation les salariés des entreprises du
territoire cette année pendant 3 mois
trois grandes entreprises se sont
associé à cette application à travers un
concours l'occasion de faire un bilan
sur cette
initiative pour ces salariés le cou
voiturage c'est du concret ils ont tous
participé au WAZ up tour un challenge
entre quatre entreprises pour inciter
les employés à se déplacer autrement bah
déjà en fait mon trajet boulot travail
c'est un bonentours de 20 km pour moi
c'est un petit peu fatiguant du coup
c'est bien de trouver quelqu'un pour
partager avec lui ce trajet là aussi de
point de vue environnemental et puis il
y a aussi la raison économique des
petites économies pour les salariés un
succès pour la startup grâce à son
application elle propose aux entreprises
de mettre en relation leurs
collaborateurs pour faciliter le
covoiturage un service gratuit pour eux
que l'entreprise finance en un an W up à
su grandir et conquérir de nouvelles
sociétés en Île-de-France alors
aujourd'hui on se développe on est parti
à deux fondateurs on est maintenant CIN
personnes dans l'entreprise don quatre
personnes en CDI donc voilà l'idée c'est
vraiment que les entreprise finance le
modèle et plus on va avoir de clients
plus on va investir sur la technologie
pour continuer à l'
et aujourd'hui la santé est bonne
puisque on
a on va à mi-205 doubler le chiffre
d'affaires de 2014 le covoiturage une
des solutions du Plan de Déplacement
interentreprise depuis 2008 les sociétés
dont plus de 500 salariés viennent en
voiture ont l'obligation de trouver des
solutions pour faciliter d'autres moyens
de transport comme ILT une des premières
entreprises à avoir conclu un
partenariat avec wup on va continuer à
insister inciter nos employés à
covoiturer parce que c'est un point
important de notre Plan de Déplacement
entreprise dans la région où on est où
les transports en commun sont quand même
encore peu nombreux pas forcément
toujours adapté aux horaires de travail
et bien oui le covoiturage est
certainement l'un des moyen collaboratif
pour le plus le plus intéressant avec la
pollution et les futures mesures pour
limiter l'utilisation des voitures de
nombreuses entreprises pourraient avoir
besoin de tels services à 50 ans en
yeline près de 15000 personnes auraient
déjà été impacté par le WAZ up Sky
tour et nous allons continuer sur ce
sujet les plans de déplacement
interentreprise et ses enjeux c'est
notre notre entretien pardon de la
semaine c'est tout de
suite et pour cet entretien je le
rappelle nous recevons Bernard Bor donc
secrétaire de l'association Horizon
employeur et chargé de mission chez Daso
système et Monsieur François Bellini é
Luu à la chambre de de commerce et
d'industrie de Versailles yelin vous
êtes tous les deux très concernés par
les plans de développement
interentreprise et les plans de
développement de reprprise ces projets
qui sont mis en place pour inciter les
collaborateurs des entreprises à réduire
l'usage de leur voiture individuelle au
profit d'autres modes de transport moins
polluant donc c'est un enjeu
environnemental important mais un enent
économique également François Bellini
j'ai envie de vous commencer par vous et
vous demander voilà pourquoi
l'agglomération et notamment la Chambre
de commerce et d'industrie de Versailles
est aussi impliqué dans le plan de
déplassement
interentreprise bah à la base les
entreprises ont une obligation comme il
vient d'être expliqué au-delà de 500
salariés qui utilisent le le véhicule
pour aller travailler euh l'entreprise
est dans l'obligation de mettre en place
un plan de déplacement
entreprise une fois qu'on a dit ça euh
lorsqu'il y a un regroupement
d'entreprises qui sont concernées par le
même sujet euh on a proposer de mettre
en place des plans déplacement inter
entreprise donc là c je veux dire dir
une discussion à trois d'une part une
association d'entreprises qui regroupe
un secteur géographique d'autre part une
communauté d'adelot et enfin la Chambre
de commerce qui se place comme animateur
de d'un plan de déplacement
interentreprise monsieur vousoui vous
justement vous vous êtes du côté plutôt
entreprise vous pouvez vous rappeler
peut-être votre mission aien de
l'association horiz employeur horiz
employeur en fait c'est l'association
des entreprises des principales
entreprises de véisier de Me dans la
forêt donc ça représente une quarantaine
d'entreprise soit 30000 salariés sur un
pôle d'emploi qui fait à peu près 43000
bon on a en plus de ça les centres
commerce o à gérer en plus on n présente
pas et la problématique est
effectivement d'arriver à se déplac à se
déplacer puisque de toute façon vé est
très contat à partir de là bah
l'association essaie par tous les moyens
de mettre en place les solutions
nécessaires éventuellement avec des
partenaires parce que les transports en
commun c'est clair que c'est pas nous
tout seul alors nous avons vu dans le
sujet président wup donc l'initiative du
covoiturage pour les déplacement
interentreprise est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer un petit peu les autres
les autres moyens de transport et les
autres initiatives qu'on peut mettre en
place dans ce cadre là alors les autres
initiatives elles sont classées par axe
dans notre Plan de Déplacement on
retrouve effectivement l'incitation à
utiliser les transports en commun ce qui
veut dire qu'il faut qu'il soit efficace
c'est qu'il répondent aux besoins des
utilisateurs àure également aussi et ça
pour nous le problème qu'il y a c'est
qu'on a une desserte par bus
principalement et ça dépend de deux axes
principaux qui sont quand même assez
chargés RN8 et à 86 mais il faut
également qu'il soit connu on s'aperçoit
qu'il y a des gens encore qui ne savent
pas qu' des lignes qui passent juste à
vos pied de leur immeuble bon ça c'est
la première possibilité les transports
en commun ensuite c'est les circulations
douces donc bon le vélo c'est vrai que
sur Bisi qui est quand même sur un
plateau c'est pas facile à gérer il y en
a quand même qui le font parce que ça
leur fait leur sport du matin bon c'est
la marche à pied parce que bon il y a
des fois pour terminer depuis l'arrêt du
TR le plus proche 10 minutes à pied ça
peut être une solution et après bah ça
peut être d'autres choses comme le
courvoiturage l'autopartage et cetera
quel quel initiative la CCI essaie de de
de pousser c'est le couoiturage c'est
plus la marge je ne sais pas la la
Chambre de Commerce se place comme un
organisateur donc l'objectif est plutôt
de défendre une méthodologie d'aide aux
entreprises on fait le point avec les
entreprises et les salariés des
entreprises en fonction de chaque site
donc en terme de PDI dans les Evelin on
a quatre PDI qui sont présent et on va
essayer de définir pdiie par pdiie le
l'ensemble des besoins certains peuvent
être effectivement définir une méthode
de couvoiturage d'autres peuvent mettre
l'accent sur la mise en place de de de
mode doux c'estd des vélos des roller et
cetera d'autres peuvent avoir besoin de
mettre en place un parking spécifique
pour les vélos puisque ça a été mis en
place également ou ça peut être
également une négociation vis-à-vis du
sttif lorsque on veut que l'horaire soit
déplacé qu'un déplacement de bus soit
effectué parce que la rotation du bus ne
correspond pas tout à fait à ce qu'il
faut et et essayer aussi par exemple de
de décaler les horaires de travail ça
peut être également de faire mettre
l'accent sur le télétravail donc il y a
un ensemble de d'outils qui existent et
qu'on essae de mettre en uvre par
donc tout cela est certainement un coupt
je pense notammentilà parlez de
d'aménager des espaces pour les vélos ou
même du télétravail où il y a aussi des
gens qui sont dédiés justement à ces
plans déplacement interentreprise ça
représente beaucoup pour les entreprises
justement ce
planl il y a il y a forcément un coup ne
serit-ce que le temps homme des
personnes qui sont qui représentent les
entreprise il y a un certain nombre de
de réunions régulières aussi bien pour
la la communauté d'adelot que pour les
entreprises et et la Chambre de commerce
après effectivement on essaie de trouver
les les les financements qui vont bien
en fonction des projets c'est pas des
des des c'est pas forcément des sommes
qui sont importantes c'est plus dans
dans l'action lister lister les les les
les les points de passage au niveau de
des véhicules pour le pour les rollurs
pour les vélos les pistes citelbles et
autres ne coûte pas forc ment cher c'est
plus une volonté globale de du en
fait Monsieur Je voyz réagir vous AES
pe-être une idée plus précise plus
concret avec dans ce système non le
problème qu'il y a c'est que c'est très
difficile à chiffrer puisque B certaines
actions sont en fait bon on arrive à les
chiffrer construction d'un parking à
vélo ou des douches et des vestiaires
pour les utilisateurs des mêmes vélos ça
on peut le chiffrer prévoir des places
pour le couveraturage on peut aussi bon
soit c'est du marquage soit c'est des
places supplémentaires après essayer de
par exemple tout ce qui est effort de
sensibilisation bon ça veut dire
éventuellement qu'on fera venir un
opérateur ça veut dire que
éventuellement j'animerai moi-même le
stand si nécessaire mais bon là c'est ça
fait partie pon ça à un coup bien sûr
puisque pendant que je fais ça je ne
fais pas autre chose mais disons c'est
pas chiffré en tant que tel le plus
compliqué c'est de sensibiliser
peut-être les salariés bien sûr bah
certains sont réceptifs c'estàd qu'on
leur explique bon il y a une démarche
quand même pour expliquer bah voilà il y
a ça qui peut vous rendre service la
voiture tous les jours c'est peut-être
pas une nécessité bon et puis il y en a
d'autres bah de toute façon ça marchera
jamais et cetera et cetera discours
défétiste alors après B faut arriver à
se mettre à la hauteur de chacun quel
quel initiative peut-on également être
en place parce qu'il y a des entreprises
qui sont soumises qui sont assujetties
justement à ça justement je VO réagir
tout à fait c'est exactement ce que je
voulais dire je crois qu'il est
important de bien expliquer aux
entreprises qu'elles soient grande
entrepris dans l'obligation de répondre
à la loi mais aussi les petites
entreprise c'est le moyen pour les
petites entreprises dans le cadre d'un
pdiie tous ensemble on est plus fort
donc le peut parler pour le compte de
tout le monde alors que l'entreprise
s'il demande de déplacer un un horaire
de de bus n'aura aucun impact alors que
si c'est un PDI qui le demande c'est
c'est au nom d'un certain nombre de
salariés c'est au nom de de toute la
zone d'activité donc on est beaucoup
plus reconnu et la communauté d'adelot
peut forcément nous pousser beaucoup
plus facilement en 2013 donc en France
ont recensé 340 établissements donc qui
étaient assujetti voilà j'ai envie de
demander est-ce que c'est encore trop
peu est-ce qu'il faut faire des efforts
pour qu'il y ait plus voilà de de Plan
de Déplacement interentreprise ou Plan
de Déplacement entreprise disons qu'il y
a déjà une réponse dans le projet de loi
sur la transition énergétique puisque le
soil de 500 salariés que vous avez
abordé tout à que vous avez cité tout à
l'heure va probablement être abaissé
est-ce que ça sera 100 200 250 je n sais
rien mais il sera fortement abaissé ce
qui veut dire qu'il y aura beaucoup plus
d'entreprises qui sert impliquées et des
conséquences économiques parce que si ça
passe à 250 employés beaucoup
d'entreprises vont devoir faire des
efforts dans ce sens-là tout à fait et
bon ce qui encore une fois ce qui est
important le pdio n'étant pas une
obligation mais une incitation euh ce
qui est important encore c'est d'être
tous ensemble pour pouvoir améliorer le
déplacement des des salariés il y a un
ensemble de mesures qu'on peut
préconiser bon il y a des contraintes
certes on les accepte mais l'intérêt
l'intérêt c'est de pouvoir euh
euh avoir ce porte-parole qui est le
en fait et bien merci François Bellin et
Bert trambord d'être venu sur notre PL
plateau et merci pour ses explications
on passe tout de suite aux chiffres de
la semaine
39 c'est le nombre d'entreprises à 50
Anin qui participe au Plan de
Déplacement interentreprise parmi elles
il y a talè également le technocentre de
Renault bug le Crédit Agricole il existe
5 PDI sur le territoire la casqu avec la
Chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
Versailles Val d'oisiveline accompagne
la mise en place sur 5 zones de 50 an en
iveline des plans de déplacement
interentreprise et maintenant je vous
propose de passer à notre partie
magazine c'est l'heure de l'entreprise
de la
semaine cette semaine nous nous
intéressons à une start-up versaillaise
mais aussi internationale bbound c'est
son nom elle propose un service simple
permettre à tous ceux qui utilisent un
smartphone d'avoir accès à l'internet
mobile partout dans le monde et de
rester connecté dès lors qu'un réseau
est disponible même si il est faible ou
saturé l'entreprise a même reçu la
visite de la secrétaire d'État du
numérique Axel le maire pour
l'inauguration de ses locaux nous y
étions un reportage réalisé avec Michel
midoro Patrick Jacques de dixmud et
Romain rpinet pour le
montage c'est une journée un peu
spéciale pour la startup BBand même
après avoir ouvert des locaux à San
Francisco à avcouver et créé une filiale
en Algérie l'émotion est toujours là
aujourd'hui les employés inaugurent leur
nouveau bureau de Versailles la vie
nous avons développé une technologie
unique qui permet à tout possesseur de
smartphone de rester connecté à Internet
quel que soit le réseau disponible et sa
qualité de la 2G donc des SMS jusqu'à la
4G le Wii pour l'occasion Axelle le
maire la secrétaire d'État chargé du
numérique a fait le déplacement elle est
venue saluer la réussite de cette
entreprise une illustration de la
technologie et de l'innovation mine
France c'est tout le monde c'est pas un
système c'est pas un dispositif c'est
pas à ministre la frenchtech ce sont les
acteurs qui lapportent et sachez que je
suis très fière de parler de vous à
l'international et désormais je pourrais
citer bbound parmi les entreprises qui
sont nos pépites qui réussissent et qui
sont et qui sont plein d'avenir
merci on a là une vraie pépite qui est
susceptible de réussir le modèle de
bbound il est peut-être moins ambitieux
qu'un Google ou un qu'un Richard Branson
mais il consiste quand même à essayer de
réduire la fracture numérique dans le
monde en apportant l'accès au numérique
à des populations qui en sont exclu un
des fondateurs de la start-up c'est lui
Albert Schulman il est versaillais il a
créé biband en 2011 son entreprise a
grandi dans la pépinière de Versailles
Grand Parc avant de s'internationaliser
et de commencer son ascension on a eu
plusieurs prix aussi bien le web en 2012
que depuis les prix de l' du plus gros
potentiel internation
et oui on fonctionne bien on se
développe au niveau au niveau
international en Asie et au MoyenOrient
et en Afrique fournir Internet au
smartphone partout dans le monde même en
zone blanche c'est la solution
développée par la société en utilisant
une technologie basée sur le Cloud sans
infrastructure elle offre un service
internet en se servant du réseau
cellulaire comme couche de transport là
où il n'y en a pas tout cela grâce à une
application ça été déployé via Google
Store dans le monde entier il y a eu
150000 dans en l'espace de quelques mois
qui a permis du coup de faire une
première levée de fond pour financer les
développements et cetera jusqu'à
aujourd'hui où on est effectivement
maintenant à parler à des opérateurs
télécom un peu partout dans le monde
aujourd'hui l'entreprise emploie 35
personnes à travers le monde les bureaux
versaillais devrai très prochainement
accueillir de nouveaux salariés
l'objectif de la start-up pour les
années à venir conquérir les opérateurs
locaux et développer des applications
notamment en Asie du Sud-Est but de
l'opér
étendre l'accès à l'Internet mobile
quelqu'un qui est au fin fond du Vietnam
aura pas forcément envie d'accéder à Yao
stock par exemple par contre il aura
besoin de savoir le prix du riz au
marché local donc voilà l'idée c'est de
travailler avec les opérateurs
localement pour définir des applications
qui ont des intérêts pour les gens
localement aujourd'hui seulement 20 % de
la population mondiale a accès à
Internet via un smartphone il reste donc
un marché de 4 milliards de personnes à
conquérir comme le géant américain
Facebook bi voudrait être présent dans
son pays d'ici l'année prochaine et
maintenant nous allons parler d'une
entreprise d'une d'une initiative pardon
surprenant c'est l'entrepreneur de la
semaine et c'est tout de
suite alors l'histoire de cet
entrepreneur est avant tout familiale
Frédéric Perin habite à Saint-Rémi des
chevreuses dans la vie il est
réalisateur mais à côté de son métier il
veut redonner vie à l'entreprise de sa
famille une manufacture de laass il fait
fait appel au financement participatif
je vous propose de découvrir son projet
Patrick Jacques de dixmut pour les
images romain resppinet au
montage dans cette petite boîte se
trouve le grand projet de Frédéric Perin
un lacet comme on en trouve plus
celui-ci est fait main comme le
fabriquéit avant ses aïux ça c'est la
fameuse machine de mon grand-père qui va
préparer qui découpe le Ferret je suis
petit-fils et arrière petit-fils de
ferreur de laassa et en fait j'adorais
raconter l'histoire de mes
grands-parents à mes amis à table
occasion de repas et euh c'était assez
plaisant de de de se rappeler que nous
avions dans le passé des bout de fer à
nos lacet et qui maintenant ont disparu
et à force de raconter cette histoire et
ben j'ai eu envie je me suis dit
pourquoi pas la remettre au goût du jour
et de recréer ce que j'avais vu dans mon
enfance à savoir une manufacture de
ferage de laassa pour partager son
projet il se tourne vers le crwfunding
ses sites de financement participatif
objectif récolter 7000 € en 2 mois
redonner vie à cet artisanat oublié mais
aussi remettre au goût du jour cette
accessoire sur la parure d'un homme je
parle avant tout pour les hommes on a
des boutons on peut porter des boutons
de manchette pour ceux qui portent des
cravates on a des pinces une ceinture et
la ceinture on oublie le cuir mais on ne
parle que de la boucle et en fait il
nous reste encore un territoire qui n'a
pas été encore repris c'est le le lacet
avec le bout de la saque et l'idée c'est
de se distinguer de transformer le lacet
qui est un objet qui a une fonction de
tenir la chaussure autour du pied en
objet de mode il n'existe plus de
manufacture de ce type dans le monde
pour relancer l'activité fr a dû
retrouver les machines de son grand-père
afin de faire quelques prototypes il
nous fallait refaire des lacet des
ferrages de laasset de meilleure qualité
donc on a réglé les machines de mon
grand-père et on a réussi à produire ce
premier prototype et nous avons
sorti ce Ferrain qui est beaucoup plus
cylindrique parfaitement coupé mais qui
avec lequel mais sur lequel il reste
encore quelques défauts par exemple il
accroche ici parce qu'en fait il est
roulé sur lui comme un escargot façon
spirale et il accroche au doigt donc
c'est pas agréable et son diamètre est
plus élevé que celui de la tresse
elle-même donc il nous a fallu investir
dans une nouvelle machine et cette
nouvelle machine nous a permis de sortir
le ferraet qui va remplacer le bout en
plastique parce qu'il est parfaitement
cylindrique le futur entrepreneur
souhaiterait commercialiser ses produits
le plus tôt possible car déjà des
acheteurs se montrent intéressés le
projet est soutenu par le parc national
régional et la commune de Saint-Rémi les
chevreuses et pourrait créer de l'emploi
dans un premier temps je pense qu'on va
s'orienter vers du travail de tacheron
on va dire c'est-à-dire qu'on va donner
à des gens dans dans la vallée de
Chevreuse la possibilité de chez eux des
gens en nécessité ou des femmes qui ont
envie de qui sont à la maison qui ont
envie de de s'occuper gagner de
compléter leur revenus ou de personnes
âgées de compléter leur revenus on va
leur amener des lacets et des pinces à
ferer donc ils vont ferer eux-mêmes le
lacet Frédéric souhaite créer un produit
de qualité made in France à prix
abordable suite de l'aventure dans de
semaines date de fermeture de sa
collecte sur
Internet et si l'initiative vous
intéresse que vous voulez aider Frédéric
vous pouvez retrouver son projet sur le
site
www.elomerci.com c'est bientôt la fin de
notre émission mais avant de nous
quitter je vous propose un dernier
rendez-vous avec l'agenda la
semaine dans l'agenda de cette semaine
deux informations à ne pas rater les
inscriptions pour le 8e trophée des
entreprises de 50 ans en iine ont
commencé la compétition se déroule le 4
juin elle est ouverte à tous les
salariés et entreprises du territoire
c'est un raid multisport vous vous devez
vous y inscrire par vous devez vous y
inscrire pardon par équipe de trois
personnes d'une même entreprise au
programme des épreuves de VTT cours et
canoé attention les places sont limitées
aux 150 premières équipes inscrites
enfin la Maison de l'Entreprise vous
propose un rendez-vous pour les
entrepreneurs en devenir le thème statut
juridique un choix stratégique pour
votre entreprise la réunion a lieu le
mercredi 22 avril de 14h30 à 17h ce
rendez-vous est ouvert à tous et gratuit
il faut néanmoins s'inscrire auprès de
la Maison de l'Entreprise
c'est la fin de notre émission je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée je vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de
filego